[Music]
five years ago you wrote this open
letter to amanda bynes oh yeah yeah I'm
the biggest amanda Bynes fan like I grew
up watching that girl absolutely how do
you talk to her as of recently I haven't
but I heard she's doing so much better
and that's I mean people when they're
weird when they're dealing with personal
issues sometimes you got to give them
their space yeah and then when they
reach out then that's the time to do it
Nick Cannon getting candid about his
former co-star amanda Bynes we will not
before my hit single B is for boy 32
year old actress has been notoriously
private in recent years following a
string of trouble including a DUI arrest
in 2012 she knows and you know I always
to open invite whenever she needs
anything I'm career or even personally
I'm here
I would love a comeback I'm trying to
get her on wild and I we had to all that
reunion and that's kind of when I knew
like okay she still she's still working
on herself and which is an outstanding
thing but you know she's always welcome
that's a little sis right there Nick
join Nickelodeon's all that 20 years ago
in 1998 did you just realize you just
made me feel like an old man oh that's
what's up I mean it's been it's a legacy
and to be a part of that generation I
mean I grew up on the show as welding
bin that was a dream come true for me to
be a part of it and I was not only just
in front of the camera but riding and
doing the warm-up and like I grew up
with them and you know I was like it's
like a whole reunion thing so that's as
much as we can we try to get together
and make that magic happen
[Music]
[Applause]